In this video, we'll show you how to use some of Burp's unique features for testing
with HTTP2 requests.
We'll also go over a couple of key things you need to understand about the protocol
in order to use it effectively.
Although Burp has supported HTTP2 for a while, we've added some major enhancements that
let you work with requests in ways that are just not possible with HTTP1.
This gives you the opportunity to explore a whole new HTTP2 attack surface which has
barely been audited due to the complete lack of any suitable tooling until now.
If you want to get an idea of the kind of attacks you can perform using these tools, check out
James Kettle's HTTP2 white paper on our research page.
I'll leave a link in the description.
Because HTTP2 is a binary protocol, the actual requests that are sent over the wire are really
a bit of a pain to work with directly.
So in Burp, we've made things much easier for you by displaying two different human-readable
representations of each request.
We'll look at the classic message editor view in a minute because most of the exciting
stuff is over here in the inspector panel.
First of all, under the request attributes section you can change which protocol you want
to use to send each request.
This means you can effectively upgrade and downgrade requests at will, and Burp will take
care of the details for you behind the scenes.
But the real power of these features becomes apparent when you open the request headers section.
Notice that I'm using HTTP1 at the moment, and the headers shown in the inspector match
up with what you can see over in the message editor.
But watch what happens when I switch to HTTP2.
Most of the headers are still basically the same, but you can now also see the pseudo headers.
In case you're not familiar with pseudo headers, these are new in HTTP2 and are used to pass
key bits of information about the request, some of which HTTP1 doesn't provide a header
for at all.
The method and path pseudo headers effectively replace the old request line, for example.
The colon prefix is just to help distinguish pseudo headers from ordinary headers.
Other than the fact that we don't show you the binary itself, this is a very accurate view
of what will be sent to the server.
Crucially, any changes you make to the headers here in the inspector won't be normalised or
cleaned up in any way by Burp, and you're not constrained by the limitations of any HTTP1
syntax.
This enables you to construct all kinds of advanced attacks that are exclusive to HTTP2, and currently
only possible using Burp.
We'll look at an example of this later.
Here in the message editor, notice that we still provide a representation of the request
using HTTP1 syntax.
If you make any changes here, behind the scenes Burp essentially just maps this request to
its HTTP2 equivalent, so the values of the method and path pseudo headers are derived from
the request line that you see here, for example.
Likewise, the value of the host header is used to generate the authority pseudo header, and
so on.
This is great if you're just using HTTP2 for the performance improvements it provides, and aren't
really concerned with any protocol level issues like request smuggling.
However this view is not really suitable when testing for HTTP2 specific vulnerabilities
because of the limitations imposed by the HTTP1 syntax.
For example, you won't be able to put a space in the request path here, even though this is
technically possible in the path pseudo header that this points to.
The editor also performs some lightweight normalisation to ensure that valid HTTP1 requests don't result
in invalid HTTP2 requests.
For example, you may have noticed that we automatically lowercase the header names, as this is required
by the HTTP2 spec.
We also strip the connection header and prevent you from moving the host header for the same
reason.
We've surfaced this normalisation in the editor to help you see what's happening behind
the scenes, so when you send the request you'll see this taking place.
For this reason we recommend using the inspector when you're making protocol level changes that
are specific to HTTP2.
This allows you to peel back that layer of abstraction and work more directly with the actual HTTP2 request
underneath.
As this representation is completely decoupled from HTTP1, we don't have to normalise the
changes you make here, so you can control exactly what gets sent to the server and do things
that are not possible via the editor.
So what kinds of HTTP2 specific changes can you make using these features?
Well if you've seen James' research, you'll know that one of the key differences is the
ability to inject new lines within headers, so let's start with that.
If you click on the arrow next to any header, you can drill down into its name and value.
Then to add a new line, just press the shift and return keys.
Exposing the ability to do this is fundamental for constructing many HTTP2 specific attacks.
When I apply the changes, notice that the headers in the message editor have disappeared.
These have been replaced by a notification telling me that the request has been kettled.
This is the term we've coined in honour of our infamous director of research to describe
HTTP2 requests that can no longer be accurately represented using HTTP1 syntax, at least not without
losing information.
This doesn't necessarily mean that the request is invalid, that all depends on the server,
it just means that in its current state you can only work with it using the inspector.
In this case, I've added a new line inside a header value.
Strictly speaking, this isn't allowed in HTTP2.
However, because these characters have no special meaning for parsers like they do in HTTP1,
it's technically possible to inject them and some servers will just tolerate this.
If we tried to write this using HTTP1 syntax, it would just look like two separate headers,
even though it's not.
This is the real power of the inspector.
You can create and send HTTP2 requests that it's just not possible to represent in HTTP1.
Using these features, you'll be able to find a number of bugs that are otherwise impossible
to test for.
Before we wrap up, I just want to point out that there are a few new repeater options that
are specific to HTTP2 handling.
You can find these on the repeater menu.
I won't go over these in detail now, but you can refer to our documentation for more information.
You can also change which protocol BURP uses by default from the project settings.
If you deselect this checkbox, BURP will use HTTP1 unless you explicitly tell it to send
an HTTP2 request using the toggle in the inspector.
So that's a whistle-stop tour of BURP's HTTP2 features.
Most of the time, using HTTP2 will just make your attacks faster.
But now that you can work with requests in a way that's decoupled from HTTP1 completely,
there are new possibilities for protocol-level attacks.
Just make sure you use the right protocol for the situation.
You can also use the right protocol for the situation.